Flair's championship how do you feel
about today thank you
I do stand-up comedy and I live in a van
down by the river
you are real to me up all depends on
what you want I want to not be cold
anymore
do your homes come with heating they do
come with it they do come with heating
yeah I'm sold a lot of countries can't
do that you know you don't dealt with
what you have and that's it
what about Germany home and the free
land of the brave yeah absolutely
positively thank you for uh you know
being a part of the American economy
let's just try to talk to this guy hello
sir
it's not somebody talking to us what is
your name today to be honest I know
there's a lot of white people have you
seen any Asians were they coughing I'm
concerned if anybody call I don't want
to get you fired but do you smoke weed
on the job please hire this man he
doesn't even hate white people I do a
little bit I hate everybody believe RIT
so I don't look at nobody any different
even if someone blood green I'd still
like them have you seen any Asians with
green blood tonight nope there's a cool
stadium right or whatever school part
par for the course you're at the Players
Championship right here to watch the
players play what they do on them things
like every day big beats in streaks eat
gangsters roaming and parties don't
start till not in the morning